[Musique]
dans montarville si le tableau typique
de la banlieue aisée
la circonscription regroupe les villes
de saint bruno saint basile le grand et
sainte-julie
tout ce que recherchait mylène sénégal
pour sa petite famille on est fin pour
sa tombée en amour la nature au début de
la pandémie elle a trouvé la maison
parfaite à saint jean ça commence à être
fou mais un an plus tard je peux dire
que je pourrais même pu acheter ici
commence à lui pris de la valeur l'accès
à la propriété les places en garderie la
lutte contre les changements climatiques
ce sont ses priorités pour la campagne
fédérale et qui la font pencher vers le
parti libéral madame pêcheurs semblent
amener ce vent de fraîcheur leur semble
adresser ces points là et donc si je
fais mes matches et clis
s'assemble
madame thatcher c'était
une courtière immobilière de la région
de 24 ans peu connues elle mise beaucoup
sur son jeune âge je pense qu'on est
rendu là à une époque où on doit contrer
les stéréotypes et de l'homme blanc dans
la cinquantaine qui est député si on
doit surpasser ce qui a amené des
nouvelles d'une nouvelle vision une
flèche décochée à son rival le député
bloquiste sortant stéphane bergeron je
fais campagne un peu partout ancien
député du parti québécois c'est un vieux
outils je suis juste un jeune député qui
a mûri parce que j'ai d'abord été élu à
l'âge de 28 ans
donc cet argument là je pense qu'il ya
quand même une certaine limite et il a
la cote surtout chez les plus âgés c'est
bergeron tout le monde lève voler en
terre inconnue pour le québec je vais
pour l'équipe juste un gars d'équipé
monsieur bergé spéciale il est
disponible il écoute les jeunes
montarville et un champ de bataille où
la lutte se livre à deux entre le parti
libéral et le bloc québécois et ce sera
le cas dans plusieurs circonscriptions
de la rive sud et de la rive nord selon
fait l'objet fourni en 2019 le bloc
québécois a fait le plein dans les
banlieues de montréal plein
circonscription on voit plusieurs luttes
serrées présentement parce que le bloc
descendu quelques peu sous son niveau
2019 les libéraux se sont maintenues et
donc montarville des banlieues de
montréal pourrait être en jeu libéral
comble que ce soit se résume à peu près
ma pensée
même si montarville et la
circonscription où le taux de
participation était le plus élevé au
québec en 2019 les citoyens ont peu
d'appétit pour les élections on aurait
pu attendre encore un bon moment avant
d'avoir des élections
ridicule y en a plein qui rompt pauvreté
à cause de ça mais sans que d'autres
choses à faire que mal moments chauds
comme quoi
régler la pandémie la pandémie a été
particulièrement difficile pour carey de
la mare elle a dû se résigner à fermer
son restaurant de saint basile le grand
malgré l' aide gouvernementale j'ai aimé
le cope proulx est fait mais
toujours un mais fiable fait pour
l'argent donné un cadeau et
malheureusement pas suffisamment sûre
bible tout de même satisfaite de la
gestion de la crise par les libéraux son
choix n'est pas encore fait j'hésite
toujours
à ses jours entre les deux les indécis
sont encore nombreux celle de se faire
une opinion mais c'est vraiment un
changement fin d'année minutes il
pourrait tout faire basculer d'un côté
comme de l'autre issigeac audry
charbonneau radio canada dans la
circonscription de montarville
[Musique]